un juge la course suprême est en congé
forcé depuis le premier février dernier
Russell Brown qui est un qui est un
professeur de droit albertin qui a
accédé à la Cour suprême en 2015 est
visée par une plainte formulée par un
membre du public habituellement cette
première étape de l'examen des plaintes
et confidentielles mais le Conseil
canadien de la magistrature a rendu
l'information publique mardi sans doute
par souci de transparence on va demander
ça à notre invité qui va analyser avec
nous cette procédure à sec
exceptionnelle Jean-Claude Hébert qui
est avocat criminaliste bonjour
bonjour Alors l'absence d'un juge la
cause suprême là ça peut difficilement
passer inaperçu il y a des observateurs
de la cour qui se demandait bien où
était le juge Brown depuis le 1er
février est-ce que vous trouvez vous
pensez que le Conseil de la majeure a
bien fait de révéler la raison de son
absence
c'est un acte de prudence la part de la
direction de la cour et sûrement aussi
de la part du juge encaisseur qui le
juge en chef de la Cour de panique et ça
permet au moins de dire il y a un
processus le processus d'examen du
dossier étant en marche et attendons de
voir les faits et les explications et on
verra s'il y aura une deuxième étape au
processus parce qu'il peut en avoir
d'autres étapes mais pour l'instant on a
on en est à une démarche préliminaire
bon vous l'évoquez Jean-Claude Hébert le
fonctionnement il y a plusieurs étapes
comment ça marche le cheminement et
est-ce que les plaintes mènent toujours
à une enquête sur la conduite du juge
très souvent les dossiers vont se clore
à l'étape préliminaire si le juge
examinateur et satisfait des
explications données par le juge en lien
évidemment avec la plainte à ce
moment-là lui il peut déclarer que ça
vaut pas la peine de poursuivre
l'enquête et de soumettre le dossier
une formation de cinq personnes quatre
jeux et quelqu'un d'externe pour
évidemment
déterminer si les explications données
sont crédibles donc résines ou si ça
demande davantage d'éclairage et ce
comité-là lui peut décider de le faire
confidentiellement mais il peut aussi
décider de le faire publiquement comme
c'est arrivé dans les corps récemment
avec des juges Québec c'est vrai bon
contrairement aux autres cours la Cour
suprême est un peu distincte
c'est-à-dire qu'elle comporte seulement
9 juges ça pose un problème par la durée
de l'absence de Monsieur brand parce
qu'ils pourront pas siéger à 8 non
évidemment s'il sera massait quatre
contre quatre on serait dans l'impasse
alors c'est un peu un problème ça
de ne pas avoir tout le personnel
surtout qui sont plafonnés à neuf et il
n'a pas comme dans certaines cours en
Europe 10 15 jours ici il y en a 9 ça
veut dire que ils sont en fait sont
tenues de procéder de d'entendre des
causes importantes avec un maximum de 7
jours ensuite dans certains cas dans le
passé il pouvait aussi et ça arrive de
siéger à 5 mais la loi sur la cause
prime prévoit que c'est le minimum ils
peuvent pas aller en bas de 5 et le
maximum évidemment c'est neuf bien sûr
bon il y a un risque qui est quand même
plus important celui-là c'est celui sur
la réputation du juge brande lui-même
maintenant que le public c'est que
Russell Brown fait l'objet d'une plainte
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'il est en
péril quoi qu'il advienne commission pas
commission mais enquête publique ou pas
plein de retenue ou pas est-ce que sa
réputation est-elle comme
irrémédiablement entaché
je veux dire il y a des gens et je
dirais pas tous les gens qui vont se
poser des questions il y en a qui vont
avoir la curiosité d'aller voir ou lire
le jugement dans lequel il a siéger sans
participer aux délibérés ni à la
rédaction finale jugement alors ils vont
tenter de démêler la fin de voir est-ce
qu'il y a un lien quelconque potentiel
avec la fin ça c'est dangereux parce que
tout ce qu'on sait actuellement il y a
une plaindre du public on ne sait pas on
n'a aucune indication que il y a un lien
factuel avec la personne qui était visée
dans le jugement de la Cour c'est un
militaire qui était visé qui était en
poste aux États-Unis et faudrait faire
attention de pas tirer des inférences et
dire ah lui c'est passé avec lui le PLA
ignant on ne sait pas mais il faudra pas
non plus spéculer puis dire ça vient de
là l'origine de la France dangereux en
effet mais s'il y avait justement une
enquête sur la conduite du juge à
l'étape 2 est-ce que vous pensez pas que
elle devrait absolument être public
parce que là tout le monde va vouloir
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on lui reproche et
quels sont les allégations
la pression va être très fort si on sera
évidemment à l'étape numéro 2
sur le dos des cinq membres du panel qui
vont examiner le dossier parce que
les gens les gens sans être trop curieux
vont vouloir au moins que la face soit
jugée avec transparence donc qu'on
puisse savoir qu'est-ce qui se dit
qu'est-ce qui se fait c'est quoi la
preuve etc dans ce sens là oui le panel
va avoir beaucoup de pression pour
décider de faire une audience publique
plutôt qu'une audience à 8 kg et gageons
que tout ça se fera rapidement parce
qu'on voudra pas maintenir cette
situation de 8 juges trop longtemps
Jean-Claude Hébert merci beaucoup de vos
lumières
vous en prie on va pouvoir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI